and here we are again folks I want to
admit something which is that I proudly
displayed on Instagram my plaque from
YouTube which congratulate s' the
steve-o's wild ride podcast for passing
1 million subscribers of course if I'm
honest I already had a second channel
which had just over nine hundred
thousand subscribers when I changed the
name to steve-o's wild ride podcast but
everybody that ran it by said hey a
million is a million so our podcast is a
hit we've taken a couple weeks off we
went every other week but I think now
we're going back to every week and holy
[ __ ] do we have some incredible guests
lined up Wow
I really think that we're gonna just
keep building steam but first let's just
get into this it's one of my dearest
friends in comedy a guy who's a big-time
movie star and just an all-around great
dude so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Nick Swardson
people often want to call you Nick
Swardson yeah I've heard everything I've
heard Swardson mrcwoodsman
I've heard [ __ ] dildo scientist yeah
every butchering I've heard it all man
so this pain that you're in it looks
like the same pad that you've been in
for years
is that not right no this is not the one
that you've been doing in LA I'm in
Minnesota ah [ __ ]
yeah I've been here for two months I'm
in the basement of a footlocker
nice dude I was shopping when all this
went down and they just said get under
get down I'm [ __ ] here I think I
think you've got a style dude
and and I like it so dude thank you for
doing this
yeah of course love you dude you know
yeah I love you so much man like I'm
such a fan and also dude you've just
you've been a supporter of me doing
comedy since the very beginning before I
even knew I was really doing comedy
you're like reached out you're like man
I hear you're doing comedy man if
there's anything I can do to help and
I've meant so much you know yeah of
course man I was super proud of you too
I mean you came over to my crib we
talked about it and yeah you you're
[ __ ] great man it was awesome I
remember you were like I'm tired of
stuffing shoving shut up my [ __ ] like
I want to do the stand-up and [ __ ]
Wow no it's funny do I remember it a
little bit differently I remember that
when I went over to your house
you're a pro I was like a condo
apartment kind of thing and yeah and I
was like I was in despair dude because
at the time Knoxville was filming this
bad grandpa movie and yeah and I was
like I mean I was just I didn't know
what was going on with that I found out
about it like the rest of us jackass
guys found out about it from all these
entertainment website saying Paramount
Pictures buys all the domain names for
jackass 4 and then Dan and jackass for
bad grandpa and this is I was just like
wait huh like there why am i finding out
about a jackass movie like this and then
we went on to learn what it was but the
initial shock was like [ __ ] nachos
making a jackass movie without us now
were the Jackson for like oh my god and
then I remembered to thinking like good
well they got to have us in there and so
I was like trying to write ideas to
write myself into it I was like oh well
I'll do this well I'll do that and
they're just like yeah it wasn't getting
anywhere and then I was sudden I was
like you know what I was like you know
what [ __ ] it man all these things that I
wrote to try to get into bad grandpa are
so dope
I'm gonna go reach out to Nick's Ward's
and I'm gonna go see if I can meet up
with him and say Nick dude I've got all
these great
Kamio ideas [ __ ] get me in a movie
dude oh sure I'll shove [ __ ] up my butt
I remember one of the ideas was like
like some kind of a bunch of wheat grass
bicycle machine this wasn't sure if I
could say it no way before that and Nick
is like you got to explain how you're
such a die-hard fan of skateboarding
he's good yeah I grew up a [ __ ] a
huge fan I was always awful I was so bad
as well that's like one of the worst
things when you like worship something
and he just if I was just I try dude and
it just it didn't work but I always you
know I [ __ ] love ski I just all I do
is watch skate videos and [ __ ] and I
know a ton of skaters it's [ __ ] great
man yeah you do I think we met at among
other times at the fantasy factory the
rob dyrdek that yeah okay sorry each
other there ah yeah I mean anything
skateboard related it's like Nick
swardson's in this in the scene he's in
the picture my first tattoo I got was
with Plan B guys nice we were in Hawaii
the plan B skate team and we a handful
of us got tattoo scheckler and
everything we just had such a fun time I
mean skaters are kind of like comics
where not many people can do what we do
and so it's like I don't know there's
some kind of bond there where it's just
you know wait and we just don't give a
[ __ ] you are pretty good at not giving
the [ __ ] it seems inside this is one of
my tattoos always loved one of my
favorite steve-o moments ever is like I
would go on [ __ ] benders of alcohol
that were
just unreal two bottles of vodka a day
just [ __ ] gut yontiff and I would get
so crazy and then one time I was at an
after-hours and me and some two got into
this thing and we took sharpies and
threw dart boards on our chest and then
we used metal darts and played [ __ ]
darts on each other's chests and there's
blood just but pot [ __ ] buttons of
blood all over the place so gross and I
texted Stevo and I go dude I just
[ __ ] play metal darts on my chest and
said I'm a picture and he goes I'm so
proud of ya did you do a face protection
in case of dart witness no oh no that's
good did you guys ever drink together we
did not drink together because I was
sober when we first met okay yeah you
were sober by the time we met and I was
like back and forth I would go through
yeah and I remember - because I was just
starting to like go to the LA comedy
clubs regularly it was just getting into
it I had no idea that this was gonna be
like a [ __ ] a new career but as soon
as I started going to the comedy clubs
it was actually a friend of mine said
hey I'm no Nick Swardson and he said
please pass his number on to you because
he wants to be there to help you out
with your comedy super and I was just
like what the [ __ ] dude how dope is that
and super killer yeah it's hard as [ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] a crazy time now so how
was your calendar affected by all this I
what did I mean what can I do this is I
don't want to tell the same stories over
and over but the [ __ ] I've been doing
this comedy club grind for just about
exactly 10 years I I did my first my
first comedy club like you know special
engagement was at [ __ ] off the hook
comedy club and like Marco Island
Florida and and that was no
of 2010 so you know it's been 10 years
and and dude the comedy club grind for
people don't know like you're it's like
dinner theater so they're there they get
people in
they make them by [ __ ] two drinks
like two [ __ ] items on the menu watch
the show which is kind of distracting
because there's waiters going all around
dropping checks serving like you know
why like while the show is going on it's
a [ __ ] night
well that Club that you're talking about
isn't technically a club it's a [ __ ]
seafood for sure that's it took it's a
great club at some you know these some
of these places they just have like
comedy thing there right this place at
work so I've done it it's super fun but
it is a [ __ ] restaurant so right
you're trying to talk about diarrhea and
the thing about it is that they their
model in there is they eat dinner they
watch the show they get the [ __ ] out and
they're replaced and so you got to do
the whole thing twice like every time so
and on top of that you got to do it on
Thursday you got to do it on Friday
you got to do it on Saturday you got to
do it on Sunday I made between four
years I did this Thursday through Sunday
six shows per weekend and it was just
like [ __ ] ultimately I said our kid dude
I got to have a life now I got my girl
so I'm only gonna do two times Friday to
show Saturday it's still a [ __ ]
backbreaker you know and a week before
this shutdown started like my agent
calls up and he says hey dude I gotta
tell you dude [ __ ] you're graduated
so I can no more comedy clubs dude
you're you're selling out like way ahead
so far in advance of these coming it's
just not I'm not gonna look at any more
comedy club deals now you're in theaters
and the next [ __ ] week comedy ends I
was just [ __ ] there you know and
nobody wants us to really draw a lot of
attention to it but like it's common
knowledge that Paramount Pictures
greenlit actual jackass for with the
whole Jackson 5 you know oh wow of
course - Ryan Dunn the Jackson 8 jackass
8 so we just started shooting that and
then the [ __ ] that got shut down you
know I was on the set I've [ __ ]
jackass for when I got the call from my
agent you graduated from theaters and
all that went away you know that same
went away I mean who knows but dude I
saw the [ __ ] AMC Theaters is like
maybe gonna declare bankruptcy like
thank God they pull the plug on jackass
Forks you guys are so worried about
germs a little bit surprised when we
became part of the shutdown but in any
case like first of all congratulations
on the theatres that's a [ __ ] huge
deal dude I will never forget when I had
the same conversation with my agent and
interests oh it's so awesome dude it's
one of the coolest feelings ever thank
you thank you so much dude we were
[ __ ] a fight and for that for so long
because it like what even though we
didn't understand when I say we sorry
this is my co-host Scott Randolph he's
also my tour manager my producer of
everything should have done
sooner but I mean [ __ ] dude the leap
it's like comedy clubs and here and
theater start why there's such a gap in
between you gotta jump so far to make
the leap from comedy clubs to theaters
just because the business of it is so
[ __ ] weird but I yeah thank you man
thank you and and I don't really [ __ ]
care I was going to sleep last night I
told you before we started I see Nick
says how are you I'm sitting I saw
irritable I'm grumpy I've [ __ ] gotten
tired and I just being a [ __ ] but as I
explained I made this video yesterday
when it's the most humiliating [ __ ]
video that I have ever made it's called
six things
I am totally humiliated to admit right
the most embarrassing [ __ ] and it's just
awful but it's the most entertaining
[ __ ] thing and I couldn't sleep
because I'm all excited about him like
just so [ __ ] jazzed excited about
this video I was up till 5 in the
morning just rolling back and forth I'm
all excited and I was thinking as I went
to bed you know here we are like if not
the brink we're actually in a great
depression you know like the [ __ ]
world just collapsing around us and and
my livelihood like it was just about
right [ __ ] there and everything was
taken off everything was coming together
I was about to have the biggest heyday
of my [ __ ] career and it just kind of
went away and I was just laying in bed
thinking I really don't [ __ ] care
because you know what I can whether
there's an economy or not whether
there's a [ __ ] AMC movie theaters are
not whether their people can go to come
I can make [ __ ] videos and be this
excited and all I don't even [ __ ]
care about money I don't care about
anything except look at me look at me
and watch my [ __ ] videos and I can
still do that that's a good way to look
at it and at least like you don't have
one of those murder Hornets on your PA
that's gonna be video number two I I
can't
I can give away my own ideas but I
should not be giving right it's my
[ __ ] idea I said I wanted to [ __ ]
put like
it's like a [ __ ] blow dart gun kind
of thing you know and put to put this
like tube like up my [ __ ]
and have him like blow a [ __ ] hornet
into my ass that would be the idea I saw
a guy get stung with one of those and
he's [ __ ] like collapse Jesus I just
can't handle this yeah I saw guys holy
[ __ ] I guess is a YouTube channel where
he [ __ ] goes around and gets stung by
different bees and like he said he he
took it out put it on his arm and just
immediately walled up like a baseball I
mean I don't know I heard that I heard
the murder Hornets not even that [ __ ]
bad dude but again butthole
inside your butthole dude anything is
bad I don't think any bite of any kind
it's like great and you're right no I
get it dude it feels like a really
sensitive area from what my I've
examined right I get it dude my concern
is not about if it's sensitive or if
it's gonna be awful but is that the
[ __ ] the coverage dude like you blood
like the blood you're not gonna be able
to see the Hornet into the [ __ ]
because it's in this tube which is in
your [ __ ]
so it's kind of like watching nothing
happen dude like where's the footage how
do you cover this event you can just
here's what you do here's what you do
you get a beehive and put a clear tube
in the Beehive and then it goes into
your ass watching walks maybe yeah and
then you just watch every like the party
start
either's do like the honey and a honey
animal
and then plays some [ __ ] music at
Abbey DJ get a bj and then [ __ ] out
the party and the [ __ ] see that's why
nick swardson is a huge hugely
successful entertainer right they're
just coming up and [ __ ] on the fly there
yeah so dude I want to say two real
quick because I promised that I would
that here we are in this van like we
[ __ ] blew a fuse on my [ __ ] advance
so we're just gonna get sweaty er and
sweaty or as we go but not to worry
because we're making progress in here
this is our [ __ ] travelling podcast
studio and I was I was looking for Mike
arms right so that we don't have to hold
the [ __ ] mic and I'm just checking
them all out going down the rabbit holes
and then I finally decided on this one
from this company OC whites and I
ordered just like any other [ __ ]
[ __ ] they get back to me right away
they said hey the wall mount that he
ordered [ __ ] isn't actually
compatible with the mic arms they
ordered before we send this order we
want to make sure and I was like wait
what you guys are looking out for me
like that and I'm just any other schmuck
I said dude I gotta tell you man I'm
[ __ ] ordered these for my podcast and
out of the gate it's a [ __ ] hit you
know I'm just reeling off the people I'm
getting on the podcast just bragging
about how well it's doing and the guy
set off [ __ ] man that sounds great y'all
overnight you these arms on my dime if
you mention them on the podcast and I'm
like [ __ ] eight look at these I mean
there's a lot of people just listening
to the audio but just trust me
these [ __ ] mic arms are dope and that
that's where I got [ __ ] the shout out
I promised it I'm [ __ ] loved I caught
that guy right before I said dude were
eight minutes until we get on with Nick
Swardson like that let's talk that was
one of them that was one of the best
shot at how smooth was that I didn't
know I do wait until you see like by
next week we'll have this [ __ ] sign
with the podcast logo on this [ __ ]
shaggy fur behind me and it's a halo
light logo
it's gonna be all his puke on my podcast
dude is gonna be furious with me for
that shout-out but I don't even care but
any case now I've got a bunch of
questions I don't want to ask you Nick
okay okay alright but should we also
let's just tell people before we start
it I think you've got a moving cloud I
was on might actually know I don't I
don't care about that I care about the
pubic hair that Stevo is saving them to
be a sasquatch
oh my god yeah so I have our goal right
now to come out of this [ __ ]
quarantine is the theater tour starting
pube Squatch yeah it will be [ __ ]
stop dude this is that now like I die I
have this habit of just giving away
ideas on the podcast I like the idea
that it's like the people who are really
dedicated to listening to the podcast
and all of them you know they're like
[ __ ] diehard fans they deserve to get
that extra juicy inside scoop of things
that they probably shouldn't know which
is why maybe I'll tell you that I've
given away a bunch of ideas and and
here's one that I have not divulged
you'd think I'm crazy for giving away my
ideas the way I do but they're so crazy
nobody's gonna copy them so screw it and
Nick's reaction to what I'm about to
tell him is amazing but first let's talk
about this pandemic
I hear that now they're gonna keep LA
County closed down stay at home for
another three months oh man well thank
God for post mates because you don't
have to leave your house to get whatever
the hell you want and you can support
your local businesses which is so
important to do and I'm such a fan of
posts mates I'm grateful for them
sponsoring this show we are giving my
listeners a hundred dollars in free
delivery for your first seven days so
that what that means is you downloaded
the post mates app you use the code wild
ride
that's wild ride on the post mates app
and
get $100 of free delivery for a limited
time
okay so hurry up and do that right now
and support your local businesses
I love post mates and if you don't have
it you're nuts so get it and use the
code wild ride for $100 and free
delivery now get ready to see Nick
Swardson very disappointed in me I'm
getting [ __ ] breast implants dude
they could see the disgust on it's it's
more just pondering yeah what sighs
here's the thing it's not that I want to
permanently disfigure my body okay it's
that I want to I need to have this
experience I need to know what it's like
and more importantly the experiment is
to determine how soon or not I have to
[ __ ] get rid of them can I handle it
can I make it a year every I say like
it's gonna be one [ __ ] year with real
sweet titties and I gotta be and I gotta
make it for that here like maybe it's a
bet I gotta make it for a year because I
heard about a guy and I don't know if
this story is true but I heard about a
guy who did it on a bed for her for one
year and then at the end of that one
year he wasn't willing to part with them
she kept him I don't know if that's true
it's probably not but I don't know I
mean why why would that not be true I
mean if you if you got into if you had
tits for a [ __ ] year yeah you would
have some kind of attachment you can
jerk off it's at the same time yeah I
mean this this and every I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna get a dick like I'm
gonna have a baseball tied to a string
which is attached
to wax on my eyebrow get whacked so the
[ __ ] baseball goes flying and pulls
off the eyebrow and then in its place
I'm going to have a gigantic eyebrows
shaped dick tattooed whether it like in
the place of the eyebrow and the dig is
going to be shooting outcome which will
land on my [ __ ] it's perfect
teardrops but they're gonna become drops
coming out of the corner of my eye and
that's also an experiment to see how
long do i last with it do I go out with
a high like do I go racing immediately
to the [ __ ] tattoo laser removal or
do I like [ __ ] when the eyebrow grows
back do I shave it off and keep it safe
to keep it on display because I'm so
proud I don't know what the experience
is gonna be I have to find out or do you
run for mayor so the hair's gonna be
gone or it's gonna grow back in your
hairy penis hairy penis the ideas for
the did to actually be bigger than the
eyebrow so it would technically be a
hairy penis you can shave half the
eyebrow so you just keep a little hair
pad just make it really careful to make
the actual outline of the eyebrow so
that it's a properly hairy yeah
a furry dick yeah I think it's great
right I think it's great and then if you
go that way oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and each one of my armpits nice each one
of my outfits will be a full working
ladies nice but enough about me Nick
enough about me let I do want to talk
about your Netflix movie because we
watched it yesterday and you're my new
and Rob Schneider stood out to me as the
funniest guys in it oh thanks man
yeah yeah yeah I was I yeah it was fun
man it was a [ __ ] blast it's fun
doing rated R [ __ ] you know what I mean
right
it's it's just fun when you can say
whatever you want you don't have to
worry yeah the sex scene there the
there's a threesome sex scene where yeah
where this it's so [ __ ] funny this
one person is sort of being left out
like a little bit neglected in this
thing she keeps trying to get in to the
to the [ __ ] party and each attempt to
come in like there's like some thrashing
like erotic motion where she's got
kicked in the head and it's so violent
she's trying to get some action and she
just gets her ass beat like again and
again every time she got [ __ ] nailed
I just laughs I loved it when you guys
are doing movies like that are you guys
just laughing the whole time the
backgrounds are pretty serious or is it
just a [ __ ] big party it's it's
pretty bad I laugh a lot I've been told
I've ruined so many takes man because
I'll try to focus but I improvise a lot
and especially if you're with somebody
that improvises a lot like I did a movie
30 minutes or laughs oh my god that's
the one way you say McBride that cipher
I love that movie so sorry for
interrupting you but dude when you said
what was the line that you said dude
remember like in seventh grade and like
we worship Satan for the whole year I
forget what the exact line was but that
was my I've [ __ ] howled because I'm a
big fan of Satan myself oh my god
but yeah that movie I [ __ ] loved and
it was so much improvising with me and
Danny McBride we play like the villains
in the movie and so it's if you're with
somebody you don't know what they're
gonna say I just start laughing
he's gene I always just like trying to
try to make the other person laugh like
reno911.com non-stop our whole goal is
to make the other person laugh and do
the weirdest [ __ ] you could or say the
weirdest [ __ ] you could no I'm I'm
always bad at breaking up and laughing
Danny I love it man and that's like the
rule on Saturday Night Live is that it's
like super not cool to [ __ ] break
character and crack up right like that's
like a party that's considered a party
foul
well yeah but it's like do that's live
right I mean a [ __ ] movie they can go
caught all right we gotta do that again
you know when you're alive I mean the
funniest is the people that have dropped
f-bombs since [ __ ] that's a turret live
yeah that I think it's the rule now but
it was back in the day if you said [ __ ]
you were immediately fired okay like
there was no there was no way around it
if you said [ __ ] on the air you were
fired they fired a couple people just
and even if it's on accident right
everytime I do a talk show or something
I say [ __ ] so much that I I'm always
like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] say something
yeah it's like guys should probably get
asked this all the time but like you
were never a Saturday Night Live cast
member right no right yet you're a part
of this like modern age Rat Pack of
Saturday Night Live alum like Adam
Sandler's crew with [ __ ] David Spade
Rob Schneider Adam Sandler and like how
do you get into that pack like you're in
all their movies it's so bizarre it's so
random I mean the cool thing was and
what kind of help me is that I grew up
watching those dudes so my high school
was watching Saturday Night Live back
then because it was Sandler Farley
spades tighter and everybody Phil Harvin
Chris Rock [ __ ] it all those dudes
wait Chris Rado was Saturday guys yeah
rock was on SNL yeah yours talk about
[ __ ] meteoric rise dude I don't even
remember him being on Saturday like oh
do you look at like the cast back then
it was insane yeah but I just grew up on
that sensibility so like happy gilmore
and Billy Madison Tommy Boy so when I
started hanging out with those guys I
met them I already had like their
mindset was already like ingrained in me
you know what I mean so I wasn't hard
for to write jokes for them because I
knew their boys I knew what was what
they could pull off and what was their
Sensibility it wasn't hard to write
jokes for them so did you start working
for them as a writer I they
gave me the script for Grandma's Boy
Adam Sandler did and he goes we have
this movie it's a pg-13 romantic comedy
we want it to not be that so they go if
you can just write whatever the [ __ ] you
want make a crazy rate at are speaking
of writing crazy ass [ __ ] did you know
that I'm a New York Times best seller my
book professional idiot is nuts and
every copy at Stevo comm is autographed
Plus every autograph looks just like a
penis yeah I'm very careful to make that
the case and this book is insane all
right I'm gonna just start with page one
okay it says it was March 1996 and I was
in jail
the Orange County Correctional Facility
in Orlando to be exact a couple months
earlier I had gotten my second DUI in
less than a year I was pulled over for
swerving badly while making an illegal
u-turn through a red light I tried to
tell the officer I wasn't drunk just
tired
the arrest report actually reads
defendant declined roadside sobriety
tests stating he'd prefer to take a nap
and I have the actual arrest report I'm
telling you I don't waste anybody's time
with this book it's nuts and that's why
it's a New York Times best seller and
I'm so proud of it for being like a rise
and fall redemption story of addiction
that it's meaningful for me to get it
out there that's why I sign every single
copy and it's loaded with shocking
felony arrests and fucked-up drug abuse
and perverted groupie sex
I mean it's really a story of sex drugs
in a rock-and-roll because that's all I
ever wanted and then it turned out to be
kind of a an inspiring redemption story
in any case go to steve-o calm and get
yourself an autographed copy yeah okay
all right cool let's get
to it and you can write yourself in the
movie and I'm like okay so I'd already
written the movie Malibu's Most Wanted
so I knew how to Robbie genius so then I
[ __ ] wrote grandma's boy a draft of
it and they were like yeah holy [ __ ] we
love this and I wrote Benchwarmers with
Sandler for Spade and Schneider writing
for those guys and then I started
writing for Sandler then I would write
help Adam write its talk-show jokes and
all that [ __ ] I just started writing for
anybody who wanted it a lot of those
guys they're like hey do you have
anything for me
epic let me let Scott jump in there
because he is such a fan of Grandma's
Boy it's all I could talk about it know
who wrote the joke you know please sit
on my face or the Charlie Chaplin gave
me a [ __ ] or what would you know so
[ __ ] funny dude yeah I I created the
whole robot guy and wrote all of his
dialogue and that was one thing where I
got thrown off the set because I was
laughing every [ __ ] time the guy
spoke that guy's good and did the robot
voice and every single time I could not
hold it cuz it would it would crush me
do it anytime you'd be like yeah did you
write those jokes just for him or like I
created the character and then we had to
audition all these people and nobody
really understood they kind of did but
it was really tricky because I was like
now he is a real guy but he just
zaps off in a robot world and then comes
back so it's almost like a nervous tic
so it was hard for people to kind of
grasp it and we had looked at a lot of
actors then finally that guy was
recommended Joel David Moore was
recommended by somebody they were like
you got to see this dude and he was
almost too old for the part and but he
was the only guy that really really got
it and then also got the part of being
dramatic where he would there's a scene
where he's like crying and breaking down
and stuff like that so he's a great
actor so he was able to do everything
yeah and the same was like Kevin Nealon
character did you write all that too
yeah I knew that was all yeah
believable Taylor tailor-made for Dad I
worship Kevin Nealon dude
he's unbelievable or McDonald are too
like old-school SNL dudes that are like
so funny man I remember I wanted the
roast when they were trying to roast nor
McDonald he just kept reading a paper
and would like look up and die whatever
and just go back to read up I thought
that was nobody got him it's all about
Kevin Nealon firm that's brilliant
he's [ __ ] great such a nice dude
you've done shows of that for sure for
sure have you done his live factory show
like yeah I got a huge bit out of it was
that I did that's great
I did a set and then he asked me
questions and I got a [ __ ] huge bit
out of it Jer I was stoked but dude I
just like really I thought that my big
question for you were one of them anyway
was gonna be what's been more lucrative
for you stand-up comedy or acting but
now after you've just reeled up all of
this writing that you've done I'm
starting to think that it's actually
writing that's the like like over the
three how does it break down you don't
have to give me numbers but I just want
percentages and numbers what is the
percentage of a trillion no I would say
probably stand up because stand up
that's a great thing about sentiment
that's why you were smart because it's
like not only you know you have so many
stories to tell and you have such a
great fan base that it's just it's such
a unique thing and like stand-up is
always there except for right now all
right this is the only time where all
the comedian's I've talked to were like
oh we always thought we would have
stand-up and now this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
but uh but forever it was like the
Hollywood shit's Hollywood you know so
it's like writing gigs or acting gigs
they kind of come wherever but stand-up
is always consistent right it was
something I could always do I've done at
25 years I was 25 years this February so
that's something I've done from start to
finish you know rain or shine sure where
Hollywood you just don't know what your
next movie
you don't know what your next project is
so you know obviously it pays good money
but stand-up is something that you know
I can always I can quit Hollywood any
time and just have my fans and my bra
right I mean you kill it and stand up
and if if I'm right because I mean stand
up will burning you out dude I mean it's
it's a pretty little burn you up to be
pretty girly breaks and and if I if I'm
correct I feel like you've kind of like
hit stand up really hard but then like
you'll back off you'll do it like you
know here and there like you know like
is it sort of how much like how busy you
are in movies like will sort of dictate
how much time you break off for stand up
yeah I mean it's it's what it's hard is
is shifting gears so when you're writing
a movie I just put all my energy into
that so my brain is tailored to that
movie and writing for people and getting
those specific jokes out so my brain
it's hard to switch over and go like oh
stand up it stand up it's in a bit and
the hardest part I had a sketch show on
Comedy Central called Nick swardson's
pretend time and it is the [ __ ] most
insane show I don't know if you've seen
any of it steve-o but you would lose
your mind I'll send you some of the
sketches yeah dad that took up to three
years of my life of just sketches and I
quit stand-up I didn't do stand-up for
over a year about a year and a half
because my brain was so dialed into
writing sketches and other [ __ ] that I
couldn't make the I couldn't make the
switch so it was really bizarre but you
would love this show there was a sketch
that I couldn't really made it to air
called suck your own dick ass and it was
an infomercial about a band that you put
over your head and over your knees and
you get ribs by yeah and I sent it to my
agent to see if Jim Carrey would be the
infomercial and my agent was like he's
not gonna [ __ ] do this and
like yeah that was just some of this
[ __ ] that was on there it was [ __ ]
insane dude you would love it yeah I
love it
now I remember and thank you for this -
you invited me - to be a part of a show
that you put on and some like weird
weird theater that I've never even heard
of but it was like a beautiful theater
right in the middle of West Hollywood
yeah yeah I think you had Kevin Nealon
there was just like a star-studded asked
if I could Nick Swardson and friends
comedy night and I don't know how often
we did that show but but I was just
three autos I got [ __ ] yeah I'm thinking
what am I gonna do like what I'm gonna
do like I had like a 10-minute set to do
for you and I was just thinking man aw
dude I want to kill I want to kill and I
remember I decided on I'm gonna go out
and I'm gonna do my [ __ ] bit where I
tell like 100% true stories about the
[ __ ] most famous people I've done
cocaine with routinely
on tour and it was just always a killer
people I'm like aw dude you guys get
ready to be excited man time for
celebrity cocaine stories with steve-o
and people go wild I remember that night
when I did that there I was like it was
the first time where I felt like wow
maybe this is uncomfortable
even like you know in the wings review
even like you know aware of the bit I
was doing but I was like ah how do you I
hope I'm not rubbing Nick the wrong way
doing this at his show I don't think and
I was really conflicted about that bit
in general and I remember when I went to
go take my next comedy special my agent
said hey let's go ahead and leave
celebrity cooking stories out of this
special it just doesn't feel like it
fits in and I was like all right [ __ ]
I'll leave it out but then I regretted
it and I was like I'm [ __ ] so I went
and filmed it I put it onto YouTube yeah
I remember that show I'd only did a
handful of them but the whole point of
those
is I mean I'm like so scatter bring some
running the thing but I do remember you
doing that bit I thought it was
hilarious and it though that feeder it's
for those of you out that it's just a
small theater it's only a couple hundred
people but you can do whatever you want
so I just everybody just [ __ ] around so
there's no pressure you know to be like
oh I gotta do whatever it's just I just
want people to just do anything and if
it [ __ ] eats it it's even funnier
dude I've [ __ ] bombed of that piece I
would never do other people's shows and
um I remember I walked out on one of
those shows and I go um hey I just was
at a restaurant and I had this meal and
it was the best meal I've ever had and
the owner came over and he goes hey
thanks for coming and having dinner here
and I go that's the best meal I've ever
had it was so good tomorrow I'm gonna
eat my own [ __ ] and that's how I opened
and it bombed horribly and then I just
preceded the [ __ ] bomb so bad that's
like I don't care but you didn't follow
it was [ __ ] I don't think I don't
think I just felt that it was like you
know it's the first time I felt like ooh
I remember I told bill burr about about
it he was like ah man dude you know you
don't want to [ __ ] do that dude he's
like you don't want to be like bill
Burson bill Burson you don't want to be
like [ __ ] Kathy Griffin where she
makes everybody [ __ ] into her
material and then nobody wants to be
around her like oh so he's talking about
like if they're doing cocaine was like
like sherbert like God you know right
yeah you know like calling him out for
it putting them on throwing a month
under the bus yeah I can see why your
agent won't want to do that on a special
because it's like right but then yeah
that's really dicey Duke's people can be
right I've told stories about getting
[ __ ] up with people and they're like
hey what are you doing dude right but
then I showed bill burr the video like I
sent him a link and he was like ah dude
that wasn't so bad
do you know like he made Kid Rock sound
really cool like cyclins yeah it's not
like a horrible right it was it was I
think I guy I wait I remember too
because like with like my sober
like we all really care about like not
doing harm to others and if we if we
[ __ ] up going back and making it right
and really like kind of touch about all
that and like my my sober community was
kind of split down the middle you know a
lot of people were like come on dude
it's [ __ ] comedy like who cares
there's no revelations here you know
like you're talking about you're talking
about people who are all 100% known to
have had a history plus the stories are
so old like [ __ ] it and then some other
people are like so I went with the
people who said do it on the topic of
getting [ __ ] up anyhow people aren't
somehow touchy about it a lot of the
time like it's it's perplexing to me how
much you just promote alcoholism and and
I wonder how much of it is like oh
that's just Nick being like being goofy
being Nick and how much is it like
you're really you know like did you ever
that the question is do you ever feel
like like talking about getting loaded
all day and drinking two bottles of
vodka and how [ __ ] you're so wasted
the piss your pants or whatever it is
that that's gonna like get in the way or
like or is it just you get a pass and
and is it all just [ __ ] anyway well
that felt like 40 questions yes I like
it but I can answer all of them so I've
always been a drinker I started drinking
it's very like in the Midwest I was like
he just drank you know what I mean and
so my first album was called party and
that's like I was a drinker you know and
so the older I got I would go on and off
so when I when I film a movie I rarely
drink maybe one or two this is a couple
stories but it's rare so you know I just
started to promote alcoholism but I just
have a good time with I love drinking I
haven't drank for almost eight months
nobody eight months Wow
but um yeah so like I never had a
problem with you know like drying out
and you know when I would go and get
[ __ ] wild you know there were
reckless
moments and stuff like that and none of
them are embellished at all but you know
it's one of those things where everyone
everyone's different you know what I
mean so I was somebody that I don't have
an overhead I don't have a family I
don't have you know so I would just go I
was like Peter Pan I've been doing
comedy for [ __ ] 25 you know you know
you've been doing coke yeah you know
you've been doing comedy for a long
[ __ ] time when you say my first album
[Laughter]
comedy albums but yeah so I've done you
know I've gone to a I've done all the
stuff and you know it's just I
definitely do not promote or drag
everybody everybody Shrek 2004 it's
rocking and I've kind up in the hospital
many times promoting strong word I'd
take that back and I'm not suggesting
that you have a problem this is not an
intervention I just think it's
interesting because if you find like you
know I follow you I follow you on social
media and there's just a lot of your
humor they you really get a kick out of
debauchery as [ __ ] like a drunken
comedy I can only imagine I can only
imagine the fans that come to your
comedy shows are pretty [ __ ] hammered
of the whole time yeah people get
blasted I mean you know I've spent so
many years just going out and the
drinking culture I mean I've had a blast
dude I've had so much fun it's hot it's
you know it's hard to promote it I'm not
promoting but you know there are you
know moments of just funny just [ __ ]
kicking it and like you know Florida
sits being Orlando it's raining for two
weeks it's [ __ ] great hey go go home
to Minnesota and just go to baseball
games and get hammered I mean you know
you're on [ __ ] you're talking to - sober
alcoholics who have nothing but love for
the glory days I mean every day whenever
when it worked it was [ __ ] great and
we loved it
ya know I you know but you know it's
times that you know I've had so and did
you look [ __ ] fantastic
oh thanks I mean you really really do I
know I look like [ __ ] in the movie but
definitely definitely had and some more
weight on you in the movie yeah I was
coming off a show where I was a little
thick and I was just like I'm not gonna
train for this part of an office or
occur what thank God it was noticeable
and right now you look [ __ ] awesome
dude I remember when we went out to
lunch one day and you said dude I
[ __ ] stopped eating dairy and all of
a sudden I just feel so much better dude
I [ __ ] like my skin so much better
and I'm just I never wanted touch dairy
again and have you stuck with that yeah
I've been at dairy in over a decade
yeah about that yeah that was that was
huge man that's like a real game-changer
in terms of I've worked on my diet for a
long time I mean obviously everybody
falls off with her diet but I mean for
the most part I went in sick to some
random juice bar in LA or aspiring yeah
we went there together
yeah we've been there together and the
dude that was working there was like a
man he was like a white dude with
dreadlocks is like yeah hey bar you're
always sick man and I'm like yeah I'm
[ __ ] get sick and he goes no it's not
right man it's not right man and I'm
like all right dude chill and he's like
do you eat a lot of dairy and I'm like
yeah and he goes [ __ ] cut that out
man it's poison and I go what are you
talking about and he goes try it for two
weeks man try it for two weeks and I was
like all right and so I did and
immediately he goes he's he said he goes
watch two weeks cold turkey
I slept better I had more energy and
then I'd spend ten years I [ __ ] I
never get sick ever
I just everything is better and I went
back this little [ __ ] stoner dude I'm
like you changed my life and he's like
[ __ ] yeah got a [ __ ] coke he's like
the character in grandmas
that they played I'm still tripping out
on this and this writing like he was
saying we just heard Nick say I've when
I wrote Grandma's what are you talking
about writing entire movies did I hear
you correctly like right I was brought
in to rewrite it so I wrote it rewrote
it from page one and helped his script
and had already existed but I I did a
whole polish in terms of characters and
the tone of it I know the original
script was like a broad comedy I just
heard mailbox money that's all I read
how does writing an entire [ __ ] movie
that goes out in theatres and [ __ ]
kills at the box office not generate
more revenue for you than stand-up
well growls boy didn't kill at the box
office ain't hot [ __ ] diary it costs
like five million and it made like four
million like just maybe six [ __ ] so it
did huge on DVD like gigantic I remember
the guy one of the guys that ran
blockbuster was like yeah it's one of
our most stolen movies and I was like oh
that's cool he's like yeah no it's not
cool did you just say that you wrote
thirty minutes or less no uh-uh
so the first one I did was Malibu's Most
Wanted I wrote that original script okay
was a movie called suckas and it was me
and Jamie Kennedy is like a dumb and
dumber
and then Warner Brothers bought it
retooled it for Jamie and became albums
once wanted but I had wrote the original
script and then grandma's boy and then
co-wrote Benchwarmers and then I was a
writer on chuck and Larry but wasn't
credited I just did like punch up and
then I had written I was Bucky Larson
with Sandler and covert and then I've
written three other scripts that didn't
get have not gotten made yet and then I
wrote like a ton of TV pilots cool man
did you did you and I didn't even say
the name of your new Netflix movie which
is called the wrong Missy yeah the wrong
wrong Missy and it comes out when the 14
wow that this comes out when it comes to
I came out yesterday
yeah watch it now because it's [ __ ]
hilarious got David Spade Rob Schneider
[ __ ] Lauren lapkus who plays Missy
that was incredible she's intense yeah I
didn't really know her I knew of her and
was from loosely familiar with her and
then when I saw her I was like oh my god
like what she was doing
yeah that she just went for it dude
that's what you know you're committed to
comedy is when you just put yourself out
there and like for those of you who want
to do comedy like you have to put
yourself out in so many ways I mean just
being on stage but in terms of like it's
like when you saw Will Ferrell at old
school streaking
it's [ __ ] naked you know they mean
like that's all it's like you have to
just go out and beat look like [ __ ] yeah
you know like you can't be like oh my
makeup or yeah that's a good angle not
in my comedy neck I just think right
before the podcast started on accident I
can't even imagine I remember when I
first saw jackass live I did I think I
told you this Dave when uh you guys were
at the mint oh I was at that show
I'm deer I remember that what was going
down at the men oh I think it holds like
a hundred and fifty people maybe did
Spike Jonze was there that night we it
was my old don't try this at home tour
yes we do I'm slashing my tongue with
broken glass bleeding everywhere
stapling my ballsack to my leg [ __ ] I
remember whenever we man ran across this
stage and dove headfirst head to my
balls caught the other weed battery I am
and then you guys either did or showed
the vomit I've seen I mean I definitely
barf that was my thing
I was professionally bulimic orchid
insane
Salem it was it was amazing though what
did thanks man did you have a hand in
writing the wrong Missy did you
contribute to that
no I didn't that was a pre-existing
script and then I just came along and
just did my shed so it's it's nice to be
an actor and not have to produce a lab
where you can just kind of [ __ ] around
but it sucked because that we couldn't
we
I couldn't get tan or any Sun or any
things Mike our character was so pale
and so I just look like a [ __ ]
Gargamel's did you have a hand in right
and uncut gems or did you only do comedy
oh my god that I play I play the gem
what I saw theater I was like non-stop
anxiety like immediately oh my god the
first two minutes I was couldn't breathe
I felt like I was cooked out the whole
movie right yeah it was like a Cokie
thing I felt wildly uncomfortable the
whole time but I could not stop watching
it well after the movie was over I went
to the bathroom and I was like passing
some dude that I didn't even know we
both looked at each other we're like
like heavy dude yeah yeah no it's super
intense but yeah funny thing you said
like it felt like a cocaine thing cuz it
did feel like that and it's funny I
don't know you probably had this happen
where I just assumed everyone's done
cocaine so that would I talk to people
and I'm like yeah it's like when you're
on cocaine okay yeah yeah okay well
that's worth like anyway happens to me
all the time I want to live if somebody
bet me whether like you're gonna mid
link I bet you next words and like
didn't write considered like your [ __ ]
[ __ ] was funny dude
in the wrong Missy dad that you said I
was like I I thought that you hadn't
been totally in charge of what you were
doing because well I changed my lines
constantly right I'm always changing my
lines I don't even know the last time
I've done anything that was hard hard to
the script
verbatim right I would say blades of
glory was probably one of the only ones
where it I read I did the actual lines
verbatim why that one was a good [ __ ] I
mean it seems like you get best writer
for yourself
right like you don't want anybody else
writing for you well yeah and also a lot
of people hire me solely for that
purpose if they're you know to be for me
to bring what I bring and my voice you
know so they'll be like oh yeah just do
whatever you know cuz they know I'm not
gonna make it worse you know and I'll
try a million things I can do ten
variations on one line I mean that's all
when I produce for Sandler I'm running
back and forth going like try this try
this and just trying to make it you know
as funny as possible so you know unless
you're doing like a Paul Thomas Anderson
movie where it's like [ __ ] that
script is in stone or like Tarantino I
wouldn't [ __ ] with that you know what's
the difference between making a movie
for Netflix and making the movie for
like a traditional studio that's so much
better
the studio system is a lot of people are
paranoid about their jobs so you get a
lot of notes so for those of you
watching this just [ __ ] it's insane
so you know you'll be filming a movie
for a major studio and then you'll have
executives being telling Adam Sandler
being like I don't know I don't think
that's gonna work and Adam will be like
now to work and they're like ah I don't
think it's funny maybe just maybe maybe
cut that out and Adams like no I'm not
[ __ ] cutting it out that's [ __ ]
funny and they're like that damn and
it's just some [ __ ] and it's so like
that type of [ __ ] so Netflix they'll
show up and they don't have to worry
about an opening weekend so when you
have a studio movie you have to if the
movie doesn't open big and it bombs like
you're [ __ ]
so with Netflix there's no pressure of
that because it's already there so
they're just chill they're like uh yeah
that's fine
anyway to get some popcorn real pop and
like they just kick it everyone there is
cool as [ __ ]
so there's no pressure on anybody and
that's like the best and that's what you
know it's such a relief for Adam to not
have to [ __ ] deal without you what
island were you on when you filmed the
movie fantasy we're on actual Hawaii
dude that's killer yeah yeah Hawaii is
the best dude [ __ ] love it how long
when'd you guys wrap we shot February
March so I wrapped a gate years ago yeah
it was like a year ago today so what the
[ __ ] going on in Minnesota it's just a
crazy Minnesota whether it's the Midwest
is so [ __ ] in such a headache dude
it'll be like 30 and then the next day
it'll be like 70 and then the next day
of snow and then it'll be like 40 and
then it'll rain and then I'll be like 80
it's like you don't know what you're
gonna get just like I damn it
have we really not talked about the
Minnesota Vikings this whole time dude
like talk about all the time I don't
even know what to do with football dude
I it's this whole year is [ __ ] insane
did you and every it's insane every day
yeah like the murder Hornet was like
just even though what he was even space
kim jeong-hoon might be even cares
nobody even knows what's going on it's
just everyday it's like oh yeah there's
a sex tape Bigfoot all right oh yeah if
you fart you can get AIDS all right yeah
no [ __ ] idea what's gonna happen
anymore oh my god every time I do one of
these podcasts like I get so excited to
make my my thumbnail for the for the
[ __ ] for the episode and I make the
logo different for every guest and I try
to try to try to cater it to the guests
and I'm like oh what am I gonna do for
look [ __ ] Minnesota Vikings did make
it the [ __ ] Minnesota Vikings wild
ride
Podcast logo so once again the Minnesota
Vikings football is important to you
I'd like I feel like I feel like kind of
kid I have this experience not not so
much anymore because now I'm in a food
program but like I got in real trouble
with sugar it at the end of every meal
and we just come over me like a [ __ ]
tidal wave I would turn into a werewolf
with sugar cravings and I would have
this negotiation with myself like all I
want to have dessert but no I really
shouldn't but I want her and then I'd be
like aww but I'm gonna [ __ ] hate
myself if I do oh [ __ ] it I'll do it and
then I eat like a huge dessert or two or
three and then I'm just [ __ ] and just
I'm just in shame I'm in shame and I'm
beating myself up and then I started to
think you know what I don't even think
it's about the dessert I think that
there's some kind of perverse reward or
pleasure that I'm seeking in an
opportunity to beat myself up like it's
actually the shame that I'm addicted to
and I bring that up because I feel like
you're addicted to the disappointment of
the floss like you seem to be so engaged
when the biter go it hurts you so deeply
when the Vikings lose I wonder like is
it like is is your love football like I
don't want to lose secretly in the back
of my [ __ ] mind I get out what you
get a football game leg
like losing is a tasty room that's gonna
fill and jizz cream and that's fantastic
I think I mean I'm addicted to football
but I wanna win like I want to win bad
like I want to win so bad and I'm so
obsessed with it that my sister on her
second marriage it was she picked a date
that was September 18th I believe and it
was a Vikings Packers game and I skipped
her wedding and because I said she's
gonna get a divorce but the Vikings are
gonna win she got it she got a divorce
two months later in the Vikings one epic
so what's it gonna do what's it gonna do
to you if the Vikings are playing in an
empty stadium well the only thing that
sucks is that we had a really good draft
and this is a big year for us and I feel
like you know let's just say we go we
play there's no fans there's always
gonna be an asterisk next to it so
that's what's kind of frustrating is it
won't be you know it'll always be like I
had that was that season where yeah all
right so you know you want to be at full
strength so that part kind of sucks
that's what that's what I'm most like
angry about is if we have this you know
balls out here it's always gonna be that
[ __ ] asterisk so like well it's a
it's a [ __ ] it's a mother for do you
I totally take back everything I said
about being addicted to loosing
everything was going so well until is
how and this is another thing I've
learned about diet how [ __ ] psycho
addictive sugar is oh my god and how
your body like if when I cut out I would
cut out sugar so when I cut out dairy I
cut out a lot of you know like desserts
and [ __ ] like that
and your body craves it so [ __ ]
psyche so gnarly that it's it's like
wild dude and I've done [ __ ] every
drug and sugar to me it was like yeah I
would start to really lose my mind
there's like 10 grams of sugar in a
glass of milk
like how [ __ ] crazy is that
yeah I did it's pretty yeah it's famous
drugs but it's like it is a weird yeah
yeah I divide to [ __ ] go full 12 step
on it dude I'm like [ __ ] seven months
he was having the kitchen's at the
comedy clubs open up at like 2:00 a.m.
just to make him like a double breath I
used to be like super hardcore vegan
like like I was right there with you
like yeah [ __ ] dairy and the sugar like
the sugar addiction just [ __ ] was
more important to me than whether I
[ __ ] believe in dairy or not okay
it's something like a [ __ ] brownie
and the crazy thing is the whole game
wait like if I ate as much as he like I
do I do I just
it's around it's just the spare tire
[Laughter]
before we get done have to say and I
wish I said it sooner how much I
appreciate that when I did my first
comedy special that like I'd sent it to
you and and you watched it and gave me
notes and again for my second comedy
special like I you know the second one
you chipped away at it on your tour bus
I think for a while what tour yeah we're
bus the inert or what how dope is that
it's it's dope but uh well first of all
yeah I'm proud of you dude I'm always
here for you and yeah tour bus is
another level dude of [ __ ] I remember
the biggest tour I did I did 55 cities
and I was gone for three and a half
months on a bus and I remember never
forget it
two weeks into it I was already
exhausted and I called my agent and I
was like how many more cities do have
left he's like 48 and I'm like oh my
[ __ ] god and I turned to my opener
and I was like are you ready to lose
your mind and he was
yep and that's what we did I made it
like a couple more weeks and then we the
alcohol we started having booze on the
bus and then [ __ ] just God what [ __ ]
it was awesome dude but it was it took
years off my life just just the fact
this is just a touring alone and way
Kevin new cities and time zones and
altitudes and just it was just trying
it's [ __ ] insane I don't know how do
you feel like this like when you watch I
could documentary about a band and all
like that crazy [ __ ] and how much
crazier it is when they well don't go on
a tour bus for [ __ ] like two and a
half years back in the day or like two
years yeah they'll just go and like
non-stop and there's like five of them
um yeah but I wouldn't mind doing if I
were the Beatles or [ __ ] Motley Crue
the Beatles were not a [ __ ] tour bus
[ __ ] three years right they like blew
up immediately they went on like the Ed
Sullivan Show and they're like got a
golden Thrones and [ __ ] yeah I'm talking
like I and II [ __ ] anywhere we did
gnarly bus [ __ ] we did a tour bus
through Europe I have my life oh that
what must have been sick 2016 yeah
26 cities and 28 days holy [ __ ] there's
like a crazy two-story tour bus the last
person on it was [ __ ] Justin Bieber
it was just me and Scott and we were
both in a sex program but at that time
we had just both fallen off the wagon so
we were - that was my last run of
[ __ ] acting out on the way there on
the way to Europe I had sex on the
airplane
he's a [ __ ] mile-high club legend and
so I have sex in the seat on the
airplane and then Steve posted it and
then I just had everybody coming up to
me and it was just [ __ ] on yeah it's
straight up like oh you're not in the
mile-high club if you go on the airplane
with your girlfriend and
have sex with your girlfriend like I
counted like way back in the wild boys
days I met a chick at the gate and
humped her on the airplane I counted
that because I did because she was a
stranger but dude he [ __ ] met her
like after sitting down she just
happened to sit next to him she was in
the seat next to him so hot and like the
plane ticket and this was like this
[ __ ] British Airways where we're like
there's it's like a little cubby with
two seats in it and they just [ __ ] plane
took off they turn off the lights and
he's boning her Club legend as if it was
with this stewardess or I should say
sorry flight attendant yeah she was hot
she was high in the sex program - are
you in the space if you can't if you
count drugs and alcohol as separate then
I'm in for barrelling for number five
just heading barreling towards number
five with the fifth one suspending yeah
spending I'd [ __ ] ISU's my [ __ ]
buying [ __ ] with all you have like an
Amazon anonymous when I sort of buying
[ __ ] online I like on apps and stuff so
what I'm on Instagram I'll just get oh
my god I fall for it I usually buy I
bought like three hundred dollars with
the Mandalorians yeah yeah I got I got a
lay in on a secret is that the [ __ ]
when you when you fall for the sponsored
Instagram ad that that doesn't [ __ ]
come right away so when when you when
when you're interested in what
instagrams selling it with the sponsored
ad just [ __ ] copy and paste it and
plug
in the Amazon you get the same [ __ ]
thing Prime yeah yeah dude same [ __ ]
[ __ ] right away I tried to order that
toothbrush thing that you like the mouth
guard you put in your mouth and it
brushes your teeth for you it's just so
[ __ ] hit or miss dude with the
sponsor to Instagram never came in
[ __ ] it'll never come or it'll come
like [ __ ] six months later [ __ ]
richer than Steve is do you have a you
have a tour lined up for the year and it
got cancelled or did you have anything
planned yeah my whole fall was gonna be
stacked I had all these theater dates I
had like 25 days oh my god magic Matt
like you know everything I had people
doing the artwork I had all this [ __ ]
man and now it's just so what I might do
is I might record a special in Minnesota
at some of my home clubs splice it
together and just sell it on my website
and then like retire I don't think I
have another special on me you said that
as long as I've known you dude you've
said as long as I've known you you've
said dude I don't think I have another
special I mean how many you got now it's
[ __ ] hard at five uh-huh it's [ __ ]
hard that like once you like burn is
special yet you always think it's the
end ah dude it's it's it's it's it's add
this conversation with Demi Lovato about
how [ __ ] musicians they go on tour
all anybody wants to hear is the hips
don't bother us with new [ __ ] every with
comedy it's the exact same [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] what you gonna tell me the
same [ __ ] dude come on give me something
new I know I was always jealous of music
I always hate they always [ __ ] hate
it I'm like you're some anger joke like
a really good like you know even just
coming up with like a really strong
closer you know which is your final bit
I mean to come up with a band it's
[ __ ] hard well I remember when we did
that show in Harley where I was doing
the cooking stories and you came out on
stage you said guys I just want you to
know I'm [ __ ] just trying out some
new material so I'm
are they gonna [ __ ] you know it's
gonna suck a dick it's gonna bomb and it
was the most [ __ ] genius [ __ ] dude so
you know power parity for for your
humility but I your [ __ ] rules do you
[ __ ] rules dude and I love you man I
love you too Steve yeah you can call me
any [ __ ] time I'll [ __ ] eat a
birthday cake with you with this order
like just love you dude I enjoyed your
movie watching on Netflix it's called
the wrong Missy
you know like pray pray for the football
gods to [ __ ] to smile on the
Minnesota Vikings you know don't [ __ ]
with Gary is that the thumbnail right
there he just ya know in the comedy gods
too let's get back to making people
laugh dude yeah dude
for sure let's get back to [ __ ]
shoving things up our ass and [ __ ]
make people laugh yeah indeed let me
know when you're back in LA and [ __ ]
you know let's tie our dicks together
dude done look through it I'll save my
pew all right dude love you bro I love
you too anybody got gonna see you yeah
yeah party yeah all right I got
something else to admit okay when we
recorded this with Nick we asked him to
use his his phone with the voice memo
recording so we could get better audio
from his end and then after that we
asked him to send over the voice memo
but he had a lot of trouble figuring out
how to send this larger file and it was
probably the most annoying thing that
I've put him through for I don't know
ever yeah ever so let's show Nick some
love that was such a great podcast he's
such a funny guy
please scream shot this if you're still
hanging in there screenshot this and tag
him on Instagram let him know how
hilarious he was and maybe you could
apologize on my behalf
for ya putting him through that it was
tough I mean and I kept bugging him and
bugging him and finally we got it I
think the audio sounds great thank you
for listening and street team you know
what to do just love you guys thank you
whoo yeah